the Duke of Sussex has lost a bid to
bring a second High Court challenge
against the home office over his
security Arrangements when visiting the
UK well security has always been a
hugely contentious issue for Prince
Harry ever since he left his role as a
senior working role he's not entitled to
security or automatic police protection
when he or his family are in the UK he
was challenging that decision and this
case was in particular about the
decision not to let him pay for his own
protection under the police Act of 1996
there was provision for private
individuals to be able to pay for their
own policing however when this
preliminary hearing was heard at the
high court the Met Office made it very
clear they thought this would be unjust
that you should have wealthy individuals
able to pave their own policing that it
was not a fair decision not a fair
situation and it wasn't right that the
Richer people richer people should be
able to play for policing this way